bonsoir mesdames et messieurs c'était
son remède pour redonner confiance aux
montréalais créer un poste d'inspecteur
pour veiller à la bonne marche des
affaires à l'hôtel de ville bien
françois cormier denis coderre est allé
chercher dans le lieu saint si on peut
dire de l'intégrité à la commission
charbonneau le candidat dont ils avaient
besoin
oui on avait eu 20 ce matin de ce nom
donc denis gallant alors quand on l'a vu
arriver à l'hôtel de ville on a tout de
suite compris que c'était lui le futur
inspecteur général de denis coderre
jeudi futur parce qu'il faut tout
d'abord que le projet de loi de
l'inspecteur général soit adopté à
l'assemblée nationale il faut aussi que
le choix de monsieur coderre donc maître
denis gallant soit entérinée par le
conseil municipal de montréal ça devrait
se faire sans problème c'est la vie ce
projet de loi on l'a découvert ce matin
donne plusieurs pouvoirs à cet
inspecteur général notamment celui dans
les mêmes fouiller dans les ordinateurs
du chef de l'opposition du maire de
montréal dans les ordinateurs des
entreprises qui font affaire avec la
ville de montréal il peut suspendre des
contrats il peut même les annuler et
s'il le faut je vous laisse entendre
donc denis gallant et le mercader
si cette loi là n'avaient pas dedans si
ces toiles avaient été de version très
édulcorée j'aurais dit non au jeu j'ai
lu certains éditoriaux je suis satisfait
des pouvoirs qui vont mettre dévolu si
le conseil de ville entérine la
proposition monsieur kadhafi
m gallen que pour besoin de présentation
qui est pour moi une source de
crédibilité extraordinaire et qui de par
sa vaste expérience sera un premier
respecteur général hors pair qui va
avoir un impact déjà par sa
recommandation va avoir un impact au
niveau de la population
alors françois un schengen qui viennent
la commission charbonneau difficile pour
l'opposition de s'y opposer mon à des
bémols sur le projet de loi
oui c'est ça entre autres vous savez que
si une décision de l'inspecteur général
touche la stm et bien le conseil
d'administration de la stm pourrait
décider de l'inversé de rejeter cette
décision la même chose pour l'office
municipal d'habitation par exemple donc
ça l'opposition projet montréal n'aime
pas tout à fait cet aspect là n'aiment
pas non plus que l'inspecteur général
remettre en premier son rapport au maire
de montréal et qu'ils le remettent
ensuite aux autres conseillers seulement
un mois plus tard don qu'ils espèrent
quelques modifications ce projet de loi
qui doit être adoptée au cours des
prochains jours en fait avant la
prochaine élection générale provinciale
merci françois au revoir au revoir